et voilà pour ce discours annuel a
prononcé par et vladimir poutine le
président russe en ce moment même pour
en parler nous sommes avec pierre laurin
journaliste spécialiste de la russie
c'est à un exercice on le rappelle
traditionnelle qui a lieu tous les ans
toujours devant ce parlement russe qui
réunit donc les députés et les sénateurs
et cela commence toujours par un point
sur des questions nationales voire très
locale oui bien sûr c'est le premier
point de l'adresse du président devant
l'assemblée fédérale qui est la réunion
des deux chambres
c'est toujours la politique intérieure
parce que honnêtement c'est ce qui
intéresse les russes ce qui intéresse
les russes et le niveau 10 la natalité
la santé l'éducation et c'est tous ces
volets que le président poutine a énoncé
l'un après l'autre en annonçant des
mesures de manière à faire progresser la
situation et la société russe vladimir
poutine qui a ouvert son discours tout à
l'heure en évoquant une société qui
demandent des transformations celle sur
ce point là aussi qu'il est attendu
aujourd'hui
oui bien entendu parce que normalement à
partir de 2010 à peu près la russie
aurait dû connaître une progression
constante de l'économie est également du
sociétal or la crise de crimée et la
crise d'ukraine ont à cause des
sanctions occidentales ont ralenti
pendant deux ans ça a été très dur pour
la russie ensuite elle a réussi à
surmonter
peut-être grâce aux sanctions certains
secteurs comme l'agriculture se sont
considérablement développés mais
n'empêche qu'il y a un un déficit un
retard hélas il y a encore quatre ans de
mandat de vladimir poutine jusqu'en 2024
la prochaine élection présidentielle et
il veut accélérer les choses de manière
à rendre irréversible certaines des
avancées qu'il a voulu imposer
impliquèrent la société russe le
président russe qui a donc a débuté son
allocution aussi sur le sujet de la
démographie je vais le site et à le sort
de la russie dépend de son nom
d'habitants dans la foulée il a annoncé
une augmentation des allocations
allouées à la famille oui absolument
mais ça c'est également une politique
récurrente
il s'agit jusqu'à présent jusqu'à les
deux dernières années la population
russe décliner elle s'est stabilisée
il y a à peu près trois ans et là elle
commence à redémarrer il y a une
certaine natalité une certaine
augmentation de la population qui est
tombé en quelques années de 153 millions
d'habitants à 142 c'est à dire une perte
de 11 millions en quelque chose comme 20
ans et maintenant la natalité repart la
durée de vie est prolongée ils sont
passés dessous d'une d'une espérance de
vie de 64 ans à 73 ans aujourd'hui ce
qui est considérable en très peu de
temps
et effectivement la natalité
comment pousser la natalité par des
allocations les allocations à partir du
premier enfant un capital pour la
naissance des enfants qui est
l'équivalent de 600 milles qui va être
l'équivalent de 600 mille roubles c'est
à dire plus ou moins 7500 et 8000 euros
ce qui de pour un budget russe est
considérable en plus des prêts
préférentiels pour les logements etc
alors le discours de vladimir poutine se
poursuit toujours
à moscou on est toujours sur des
questions très nationale ils voulaient
attendu aussi sur
la politique étrangère russe notamment
sur le dossier libyen est évidemment le
dossier syrien qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de son de son allocution
je crois que si j'étais tout a déjà été
dit la russie essaye de se poser au
niveau international comme un
facilitateur de solutions comme
médiateur un médiateur
c'est même mieux qu'un médiateur parce
que ils cherchent réellement la russie
cherche réellement des solutions aux
différents problèmes sur le problème
libyen
les choses ont avancé grâce à une un
dialogue entre les parties libyennes
le président turc erdogan et vladimir
poutine simplement pour des raisons
tactiques
là des interlocuteurs libyens le général
atta a renoncé à signer un compromis de
cessez-le-feu
ça va être repris on ne sait pas trop
quand mais en tout cas le dialogue se
poursuit
quant à la syrie et ça c'est très
important pour la russie c'est réglé
maintenant ce que veut la russie sur la
syrie c'est avoir des accords
internationaux sous l'égide des nations
unies pour procéder à la reconstruction
du pays et au retour des refuges et en
particulier les réfugiés en turquie qui
sont évalués à plusieurs millions et qui
devrait regagner le pays dès que la
situation sera totalement normalisée
actuellement il ne reste plus qu'une
poche de résistance des rebelles
djihadistes qui a est libre et
progressivement elle est en train d'être
liquidé entre guillemets et lorsque ce
sera terminé
la presque totalité du territoire syrien
sera sous le contrôle du gouvernement de
damas et la interviendra une négociation
avec les partenaires occidentaux pour
établir une nouvelle constitution qui
est en train d'être mises à essayer
enfin et qui est en train d'être
étudiées avec une commission ad-hoc
et puis à côté de cela obtenir des
investis
ce moment parce que les besoins en
investissements de la syrie pour la
reconstruction sont considérables et la
russie seule ne pourra jamais les les à
porte et vous voyez toujours dans ces
images en direct de moscou vladimir
poutine poursuite son propos devant le
parlement russe aujourd'hui deux ans
après sa large réélection est ce comme
l'a dit mr poutine a toujours la cote
auprès des russes en deux mots vraiment
parce que le temps nous manquait ce que
son bilan est positif jusque là alors le
bilan visiblement est positif
simplement les indicateurs économiques
le montre simplement il a été obligé
comme en france actuellement de faire
une réforme considérable qui est celle
des retraites et par ses portes et les
retraite de 60 à 65 ans et ça ça a été
très très mal perçu par une large partie
de la population et pas la plupart des
partis politiques d'opposition donc sa
cote de popularité a baissé mais
maintenant que la réforme est passée et
bien le plus dur dirais-je politiquement
est derrière lui merci beaucoup pour
votre regard qui l orange rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et spécialiste de
la russie la russie où se prolonge donc
où se poursuit donc le propos de
vladimir poutine devant le parlement
russe on suit évidemment tout ça avec
attention